Okay, we're still in the file
in titled L1_Strings, and
I say a string isn't just a string for
a couple of reasons.
Number one through the .characters
property of the string strut,
we also have access to
an array of characters.
And number two,
a string can be treated as an NSString
which is a class from Objective-C.
Let's say we wanted to identify
all of the e's in this string.
Let's say it's a password.
Here, I'm using Swift's for in loop,
which we'll discuss in detail
on the lesson on control flow.
By using the string's struct's
.character's property, which is itself
an array, I'm able to iterate through
the password, looking at each character.
Let's say I wanted to replace all
the e's in my password with 3s.
For this kind of operation,
the methods in Objective-C's NSString
class can be really helpful.
Swift automatically bridges
between the string struct and
Objective-C's NSString class, which
means Swift's strings have access to
NSString methods, like
stringByReplacingOccurrencesOfString.
To see more methods available
from the NSString class,
follow the link in
the instructor's notes.